- I was a big Dairy Queen kid.
- You're not a true Texan if
you haven't had Whataburger.
- We are here, in one of the
greatest cities in the world,
Austin, Texas, and my hometown,
to try Whataburger.
- Whataburger was started
in Corpus Christi in 1950,
and since then it's dominated
the Texas fast food culture.
- How often do you have Whataburger?
- Every Saturday
- Every Saturday.
- We've had our family Thanksgivings
at Whataburger a couple times.
- So we are here to see
what the fuss is all about.
So I sent a message to
all my Facebook fans
asking what I should get.
Let's do two of the Patty Melts,
Honey Butter Chicken Biscuit,
let's do the Chicken Strips.
- [Cashier] Two Jalapeno Cheeseburgers?
- Yeah, and a bunch of ketchup.
- That was just my order,
we have to get hers now.
We just ordered $55 worth of food.
Just by pure weight, Texas wins.
- [Eugene] We should call Quinta.
- Oh yeah.
- You think she's had Whataburger before?
- Probably not.
- [Eugene] Have you ever
heard of Whataburger?
- Unlike some of the other fast food
restaurants, they never
made it till you ordered it.
That's why we used to always eat here
when I was little is
because it was always fresh.
- [Ashly] The burgers are huge.
- [Eugene] Wide and flat.
- [Ashly] Yeah, like Texas.
(both laugh)
- You have to hold this
with two hands, it's so big.
- I love it, some people might describe
it as buttery, some might
describe it as grilled.
- The mustard is really weird,
to bite into, unasked for.
- This is way better than McDonald's.
- Tastes like Burger King to me,
with like, jalapeno.
- This is the furthest away
from a garden, and the closest
you can get to a slaughterhouse.
- I would give this one yee haw.
There's no yee and haw about it.
- If I had to compare this
to a Texas born celebrity,
definitely Michelle Rodriguez.
This is fast and it's furious,
it'll probably exit me fast and furious.
(laughs)
- [Ashly] The Patty Melt
- [Eugene] What? Damn that toast though.
Ashly said that a lot
of her followers said
that this was like one of the must haves.
- I don't even like burgers,
and it tastes more home cooked,
than any other fast food that I've had.
- Anything on Texas toast.
- And then just like a shit
ton of meat and it's so good.
- I feel cheated.
Because this is way
better than Dairy Queen.
- I would give this three yee haws.
- What celebrity is this?
This is definitely Selena Gomez.
This Patty Melt can get
it, just like Selena Gomez.
- I've seen Eugene drunk, and the man
can put away so much fast food.
- What?
Whatachick'n.
- [Ashly] Whatachick'n,
why doesn't everything
come with a side of white gravy.
Everybody said Chicken Tenders with Gravy.
- That's a good batter.
- That's like a well spiced chicken.
- I wouldn't kick this out of bed.
- I give it two yee haws,
it's like perfectly acceptable
but relatively bland.
- This is like the Owen
Wilson of Whataburger.
- I could drink this,
the gravy is delicious.
- Cheers.
- [Ashly] Ewwww. (laughs)
Fries, never leave unattended.
They're funny at Whataburger.
- [Eugene] Yeah.
- [Ashly] And spicy ketchup.
- When I go to Korean restaurants,
I always judge a restaurant
by their kimchee.
With fast food, you always
judge it by the fries.
- The fries, very mediocre.
- I had such high
expectations for these fries.
- Oh, so soggy.
- These are like Lance Armstrong honestly.
I'm gonna try the spicy ketchup.
- Mmm.
- Oh hell yeah!
That changes everything.
- Like sweet and sour sauce,
and ketchup had a baby.
- Has like a sriracha flavor.
- I would give this four yee haws.
I think my skin is getting greasier
by the second eating this food.
Good lord.
- [Eugene] It smells so good.
- [Ashly] Ohh! Yes.
- [Eugene] That is just,
pooping honey butter.
I have never seen anything like this
at a fast food establishment.
- Oh my God.
- It's just oozing this buttery goodness.
- [Ashly] Mmm.
- It's a sexy looking
piece of meat.
- I do! (laughs)
You should come to Texas
just so you can eat this.
- This is the Beyonce of
Whataburger items, my god.
- It's so good it melts in your mouth.
This is like seven yee haws
out of a one to five scale.
- I have the biggest food boner right now.
Is that gross?
Is that gross? Sorry Ashly.
- [Ashly] Overall I understand
why people love Whataburger.
- It made me say "what a
(bleeped) good ass burger."
- It's like very Texas
though, there's so much flavor
packed into everything,
everything is way too big.
This is a medium.
- You can take the boy out of Texas,
but you can't take the
Texas out of the boy.
Maybe you'd like marry In-N-Out but,
Whataburger, you would just have
sex with Whataburger like every night,
Do I keep making food into sex?
- [Ashly] That is so sexual.
- I'm sorry.
- My skin is already terrible
from eating two things.
Eugene's fine, he's shaking a little.
- I farted a bit.
(laughs)